[Music]
my name is Robin sued Fisher and I'm the
founder and chief ice-cream maker at
smitten ice-cream started off actually
at the GSB when I drove into
entrepreneurship and took a bunch of
classes in that space and decided to
focus on something I loved and was
passionate about and that was ice cream
my goal was to take a product I love and
make it even better looked into the
science behind ice cream and figured out
that a lot of the quality of the product
is a result of ice crystal formation the
colder you freeze a product the smaller
the ice crystals can be and the smaller
the ice crystals the smoother the
texture can be so if I could actually
freeze it really really cold I could
make it to order I started playing
around with liquid nitrogen which is
negative 321 degrees Fahrenheit and I
started literally at GSB I was sourcing
a tank of liquid nitrogen and making ice
cream in my backyard and pretty much by
the end of my two years there I was
known as the ice cream girl some people
didn't even know my name I was just the
ice cream girl actually spent the next
two years after the GSB working in a
basement shop with a brilliant engineer
and really just making ice cream over
and over again with different types of
mixing devices and we ended up with a
prototype of our now machine that we use
in our shop which we call burr what I
decided to do was just sort of go rogue
a little bit and figured I need
something to carry this you know forty
pound stainless steel device and a tank
of liquid nitrogen and I also wanted
something to sort of prove that I was
trying to do a wholesome approach to ice
cream despite that it looks kind of
modern so the Radio Flyer wagon idea
sort of came about
I was telling someone that I was selling
on the street and they're like Oh Wall
Street and I was like I have the the
street as in B Street and so that was my
life for the next nine months I just
sold ice cream on streets and alleys and
parks in San Francisco actually got to a
point where I was totally fine with it
not working I just wanted to know and
then we started getting lines and lines
of mines and selling out every day so we
were able to create enough momentum to
open up our first shop in Hayes Valley
San Francisco and that shop has now been
open for two years it's a very very
interesting shop and not it's actually
built out of a 40-foot long recycled
shipping container and what we did is we
cut that shipping container in half and
half is our tiny little kitchen and half
is our open retail front bar and on that
front bar you will see four of our bure
machines you can interact and watch your
very own ice cream being made right in
front of you
[Music]
actually get to see this fog it's a
legend in vapour that forms around them
scenes San Francisco fog over the
machine it has a double helical mixer
which together sort of scrapes every
surface of itself to create the
exceptionally small ice crystal and then
it has dietary software that controls
viscosity inducing so it it actually
gives real-time feedback and the machine
is quote smart and it knows when it's
created the perfect scoop and it stops
for you I think it's really hard to do
two things better than anyone else in
the world so we don't we just focus on
that one thing and we make sure that
everything that comes out of our shop is
that one thing done as best as possible
having such a small menu allows us to
pick the best of the best ingredients
and make sure that every single flavor
is his perfect as we can make it
it was delicious so we got the salted
caramel and it was very cold was what
Emily said about it she remarked how
cold it was but it was very smooth when
I eat their ice cream it tastes very
natural you could see like where it's
coming from they are full disclosure
around like the ingredients which is
always nice
I'd been in the consulting world and had
done a lot of biotech and healthcare and
large scale big companies and I really
wanted to go after something that was
more personable and actually got a real
human reaction from people ice cream was
always a thing for me and my family that
brought people together and was always a
thing that was a delightful moment in
the day
my advice for entrepreneurs is go after
something that you love and not just a
business idea I didn't have you know any
real success until you're four and so I
definitely don't think I could have kept
going unless I really loved what I was
doing
I've got about ten different hats that I
get to wear but it all comes down to
making people happy I definitely make
sure that part of my day is just seeing
the smiles in the faces of the customers
who come through the door it's me very
grateful to be to be where I am and for
the the path that I've taken
[Music]